je tiens tout d'abord avec l'ensemble
des députés des républicains en cette
période de canicule et de risque d'
incendies très élevé a salué l'action de
nos sapeurs pompiers qui agissent au
quotidien au service de la protection
des français
soyez attentifs à leurs revendications
monsieur le ministre monsieur le premier
ministre
les français aspirent à pouvoir
travailler et vivre de leur travail
alors pourquoi le gouvernement plutôt
que de prendre des mesures punitives
n'accompagne at il pas des entreprises
dans leur développement
source de richesse et de création
d'emplois c'est ainsi que le chômage de
masse pourra être réservé à force de
critiquer notre modèle depuis ces
dernières années et de distiller ce
message vous amplifier son déclin la
production agricole française stagne en
volume alors que celles de ses
concurrents augmente
l'excédent commercial agricole a été
divisé par deux en cinq ans et il risque
de disparaître en 2023 les importations
augmentent
un tel point qu'aujourd'hui les français
consomment plus d'un jour par semaine
uniquement des produits agricoles
importés et qu'un quart de ceux ci ne
respectent pas les normes imposées en
france un légume est un fruit suis sur
deux sont importés un quart du port
l'est aussi et même le jambon bio vient
d'espagne
alors monsieur le premier ministre êtes
vous conscient de cette réalité je le
premier ministre derrière le
développement annoncé du réseau de votre
administration
les élus locaux ont davantage le
sentiment d'un nouveau repli
territoriales notamment dans les
territoires fragiles j'ai donc trois
questions quelles garanties offrez-vous
aux particuliers et aux entreprises
quant à la qualité des services qui sont
rendus dans les futurs accueil de
proximité
quelles garanties offrez-vous aux
collectivités d'une part quant à la
qualité du conseil financier apporté par
le futur conseiller aux collectivités
dont le périmètre d'action couvrira une
intercommunalité et d'autre part sur la
prise en charge financière que tu
glissement des tâches de la direction
des finances publiques vers les communes
notamment les prises de rendez-vous ou
la gestion des premiers accueils
enfin quelles garanties offrez-vous aux
agents de votre administration qui
s'inquiètent du devenir de leur mission
et de leur lieu de travail
les chiffres de la préfecture de police
nous rappelle que plus de 45% des
personnes mises en cause dans ces
nouvelles délinquance sont des migrants
la préfecture de police dont je salue
l'efficacité de la nouvelle gestion de
l'ordre public
face à la crise des gilets jaunes parle
je cite de l'effet important des vagues
migratoires
c'est dans le monde du 21 juin alors
monsieur le ministre
l'insécurité devient la préoccupation
quotidienne des parisiens
des quartiers entiers sont désormais des
zones de non droit
que comptez vous faire contre cette
déflagration de la délinquance sur le
premier ministre vous avez vous même à
maintes reprises exprimé votre
compréhension des difficultés des
français dès territoires où l'on
parcourent de longues distances de la
réalité scientifique de moteurs diesel
moderne vertueux dont on détourne
abusivement les choix des consommateurs
malgré tout notre filière automobile est
sacrifié sur l'autel d'un dogmatisme
aveugle
la majorité vient d'interdire la vente
de véhicules thermiques à horizon 2040
alors que manifestement la france n'est
prête ni sur le volet industriel ni pour
nos concitoyens des territoires ruraux
[Musique]